and finally here at five catholic
charities is celebrating 80 years
they've been given back to the community
since 1941
and they say their mission hasn't
stopped but only evolved over time
they say they're really looking forward
to the next 80 years and beyond they do
so much good work so to honor
all of the giving they've done over the
last eight decades the charity hosted a
special community meal for clients and
staff
we've started serving meals in 1965 and
it's been a tradition that we've carried
on ever since then
several decades where we've served a
free meal to anyone who's hungry
that's always taking place indoors in a
dining room so it's a little different
this year we're doing this special meal
outside an
outdoor pavilion but we're very grateful
to all of our community partners for
allowing us to
to do this and to help us to help us
create a place and a space where we can
take care of those in need
not only take care of those in need but
they also have a program to help people
and their pets bringing dog and cat food
as well
so for instance today's meal consisted
of over 600 pounds of beef brisket
75 gallons of baked beans 1 200 ears of
corn
and 1200 slices of carrot cake of course
for dessert that's how they do it
how to get huge amounts of food to a lot
of people be it 600 pounds of brisket or
something else
it's catholic charities they just have
been doing selfless
incredibly kind work for now eight
decades and they are celebrating it well
deserved
they should be applauded for all they do
in the valley yeah they're one of many
great charities here in town that is for
sure